hey it's Alexis Madrigal reporter with
wired science we're here at swiss and x
which is an organization that helps
collaborations out between the United
States and Switzerland around science
and technology they're hosting a party
with a ton of the physical from all
across California an up and down the
west coast to talk about and celebrate
the Large Hadron Collider we're going to
go in we ran some interviews with this
and they're going to tell you their
hopes and dreams for the largest biggest
baddest particle accelerator ever crater
awesome post that's a true you think the
people who may then work and we hope
that we have another 15 years of good
finish I am too in hewitt from the
Stanford Linear Accelerator Center
businesses and I've been waiting for
this day for 25 years my name is Gordon
Watson from the University of Washington
up in Seattle and I'm one of the many
members here the Atlas experiment
and so I'm here celebrating the start up
of the LHC and I was just mentioning
they had a great video that they piped
in from the days of festivities when the
first theme was actually circulating and
you can just see the joy in the people's
faces but there's this one woman in
particular that really sticks out partly
because she's very close to the camera
but you can just see the light coming
out of her eyes and she apparently sent
an email around later and said this was
the happiest day of her life okay I'm
Jim Siegrist from Berkeley and I've been
working on the lacs a long time ago 1994
so and I thought that we're gonna find
dark matter particles at the LHC which
will be more exciting than anything you
can stand I'm andreas Albrecht I met UC
Davis in the physics department
I I'm very excited about the LHC this is
an experiment that's been it's been
booming in the future my entire career I
guess my hopes are first of all that we
understand in the end where mass comes
from this is the fundamental question
that is left on answer we have ideas
about it we have theories of all pointed
to the LHC energies is that where we
should find the ultimate answer I'm
Steve Brule I'm a director of a
accelerator in fusion research division
at Berkeley Lab and you know i think the
LHC is probably know the most exciting
things technologically that that the
world seems period period you can land a
man on the moon and technologically
that's fantastic but in terms of science
there's no greater project in the LHC
I'm a PhD student at UC Berkeley and I
have been working on FSI started working
on FS as a summer student at CERN like
two years two and a half years ago so I
haven't been involved for very long I
sort of it's amazing summer skies were
saying that we working on Apple's things
like 90-84 that's my entire life I was a
first year graduate student in 1983 when
it was first announced that
superconducting supercollider we were
going to pursue building that new
and I've been doing calculations for
Hydra and super colliders ever sentence
what I've done over the past 25 years
says take every new crazy theory that
anybody's ever come up with and
calculated its signature at the SSC or
the LHC I guess is he was cancelled and
my home for what the LHC will find is
none of the above honestly think it's
going to be as a promise because I think
nature is smarter than we are and she's
got surprised more for us and we're
going to have a fun time trying to
figure out everything you when you're
building these things you're you're
building something that's very small so
it's it's an order an art and a half
long when you start
diameter but then you build hundreds of
thousands of these and glue them
together and it comes something that is
many many many meters high four or five
stories high and it's been incredible to
watch that happen and then watch over in
CERN as they call it into place put it
down in through the hole down into the
pit or the actual detector arrests many
nerves many feet underground and you
know that you worked on those little
tiny tubes and you know they're this one
small part of times many hundreds of
thousands in this huge detector and
that's a kind of cool feeling because
they saw some signals in those today so
something I touched actually had a
little blip today during some of these
tests clinic are stuck at the University
of California Santa Cruz and theoretical
particle businesses physics and I just
like to say that we don't need to worry
about the LHC destroying the universe in
an election era where is a crazy woman
you know shooting big game out of
airplanes okay Howard haber University
of California Santa Cruz maybe just talk
a little bit about you know your hopes
for the LHC made yeah well I'm a
theoretical particle physicist so I've
been spending a long time during my four
trying to understand basically
electroweak symmetry and how it works
and one of the big missing pieces from
that story is possibly a new particle
the Higgs boson so what do you think do
you think they're going to find I think
they will and quickly no it's actually
if it's if the mass of the Higgs boson
is where we think it is and we think it
is based on indirect evidence from other
experiments it will probably take about
three years so to be honest I do not
care that much about the Higgs just
because everyone is talking about the
Higgs it's like the Expos and things
goes in there oh my name is Lauren
Tompkins I am a graduate student at UC
Berkeley I'm working on the Atlas
experiment LHC extra dimensions would be
really pretty awesome to find that you
know there's many theories come up with
having extra mentions but have tangible
proof of extra dimensions I think would
be like completely revolutionary and all
my friends are getting this like we
nice jobs getting a very nice paycheck
and you know i'm a PhD students but on
the other hand especially on a day like
this I just want to know how the
universe works tell me was really sunk
in yet we're actually here we're
actually getting ready to look at the
physics and actually think about it
we've been planning for the last 20
years like how do we discover the Higgs
how do we look for something beyond the
standard model or supersymmetry or
something like that and we're finally to
the to the point where that's on the
horizon and I have to plan for that I
have to get my students ready for that
is it stressful and firm oh yeah
completely I have this shot gray hair
now and my wife claims is because I just
we have a new kid but it's really
because of the other sleep